you've written about this idea of
virtuality on this topic which you
define as the subjective phenomenon of
knowingly engaging with virtual
sensation and perception and suspending
or forgetting the context that it's uh
simulacrum
so let me ask
uh
what is real
is there a hard line between reality and
virtuality like perception drifts from
some kind of physical reality we have to
kind of have a sense of what is the line
that's to we've gone too far right right
for me it's not about any hard line
about physical reality as much as
um a simple question of
um does the particular technology help
people connect in a more integral way
with other people with their environment
with all of the full spectrum of things
around them so it's less about oh this
is a virtual thing and this is a hard
real thing more about when we create
virtual representations of the real
things
always some things are lost in
translation usually many many dimensions
are lost in translation right we're now
coming to
almost two years of covid people on zoom
all the time you know it's different
when you meet somebody in person than
when you see them on i've seen you on
youtube lots right
but the senior person is very different
and so
i think when we
engage in virtual experiences
all the time and we only do that there
is absolutely a level of embodiment
there's a level of embodied experience
some participatory interaction that is
lost
and it's very hard to put your finger on
exactly what it is it's hard to say oh
we're gonna spend a hundred million
dollars building a new system that
captures this five to five five percent
better higher fidelity human expression
no one's going to pay for that right so
when we rush madly into
a world of simulacrum and and virtuality
um
you know the things that are lost are
it's difficult
once everyone moves there it can be hard
to look back and see what we've what
we've lost so is it irrecoverably lost
or rather when you put it all on the
table
is it possible for more to be gained
than is lost if you look at video games
they create
virtual experiences that are surreal
and can bring joy to a lot of people can
connect a lot of people uh and can get
people to talk a lot of trash uh
so they can bring out the best and the
worst in people so is it possible to
have a future world
where the pros outweigh the cons
it is i mean it's possible to have that
in the in the current world but
um when
literally trillions of dollars of
capital are tied to using those things
to
groom the worst of our inclinations and
to attack our weaknesses uh in the
limbic system to create these things
into id machines versus connection
machines
then um then the those good things don't
stand a chance can you make a lot of
money by building connection machines is
it possible do you think
to bring out the best in human nature to
uh create fulfilling connections and
relationships in the digital world and
make a [ __ ] ton of money
um if i figured out i'll let you know
but what's your intuition without
concretely knowing what's
my intuition is that a lot of our
digital technologies give us the ability
to have synthetic connections or to
experience virtuality
they have co-evolved
with
sort of the human expectations it's sort
of like sugary drinks as people have
more sugary drinks they get they need
more sugary drinks to get that same hit
right so with these virtual things
and with tv
and fast cuts and you know tick tocks
and all these different kinds of things
we're co-creating essentially humanity
that sort of asks and needs those things
and now becomes very difficult to get
people to slow down it gets difficult
for people to hold their attention
on on slow things and actually feel that
embodied experience right so mindfulness
now more than ever is so important in
schools and um as a therapy technique
for people because our environment has
been accelerated and mcluhan actually
talks about this in the electric
environment
of the television and that was before
tick-tock and before front-facing
cameras so
i think for me the the concern is that
it's not like we can ever switch to
doing something better but more of the
humans and technology
they're not independent of each other
the technology that we use
kind of molds what we need for the next
generation of technology
you